well thank you very much to all of you
there was so much to think about there I
want to begin by actually picking up
that last point that Tony made if I may
with you for Hannah you're in a hurry
the the motion says it all we're talking
about climate collapse why worry about
overturning the system why not work with
what you've got because we've been
trying for 30 years to have legally
binding targets and caps and they
haven't happened so it's not like we've
not not thought about any of these
things you know we've got to the point
of rebellion because we've understood
that the system cannot create the
solutions that are necessary for its own
transformation in a more sort of elegant
way audre Lorde's who is a feminist poet
thinker strategist you know so said it
very nicely actually she said for the
Masters tools will never dismantle the
Masters house they may allow us to
temporarily beat him as his own game but
they will never enable us to buy genuine
change that's my insight from the last
30 years we've been banging our heads
trying to do exactly these things and
the very industries the very countries
that are dependent then on these
industries because in tarah countries
are then dependent on some of the
largest industries are not making the
change I did want to add one more very
large subsidy which is the military so
fossil fuel you know takes place now
largely in hugely authoritarian regimes
the destruction of nature is backed by a
fist of force nature defenders are being
killed and those regimes are held
together that is an additional cost in
the system and we don't talk about it
and it requires radical change at
Arizona you were a regulator in various
different guises why are we still having
this conversation now if it was possible
to drive through the kind of change that
Tony was talking about well because we
didn't win the argument but we've gotta
win the argument but I think the
challenge for George and for Hana is
they say we fail to win these arguments
in the past lobbying and
power of money has prevented having
tight enough a you know rules and
regulations so we're going to abolish
capitalism but you're gonna have to win
the argument for abolishing capitalism
why is it going to be easier to win the
argument for abolishing capitalism than
to win the argument for regulating
capitalism the point is we've got to win
the argument and once we've won the
argument and got the legally binding
targets that Tony talks about we will
then find that having a market place
which helps you work out the details of
it will be better than having public
ownership of the means of production and
distribution in exchange because I do
think it is incumbent on for Hana and
Jorge to say what the alternative is so
it's very easy to say we hate capitalism
it's not going to work
the alternative is public ownership of
the means of production of distribution
exchange and we know that when that was
applied in Eastern Europe and Russia the
environmental impacts of that were far
far worse than the impacts of capitalism
you began to talk about a possible
alternative do you want to expand on
this private sufficiency public luxury
yes so the principle of it is it's not
state control I'm not a communist you
know there's this assumption that if
you're against capitalism you have to be
a communism as if the Communist is if
there's only two options in this
fascinating and complex world but they
massively neglected sphere of the
economy and the one which delivers both
equity and environmental protection is
the one that no one ever talks about
which is the Commons we discuss this as
if there's only two kinds of economy
there's a market and there's a state but
actually the Commons which is used to be
huge is huge in some people's lives is a
bit where we control what goes on around
us neither the state does it neither the
market does it we can control public
services we can control and we the local
communities are able then to exercise
far more power in decision-making
than we can under either of those other
systems either capitalism or communism
both take power away from us I'm all for
taking back control but not in the way
that dominate comments
Sonne juniper come on what's what's
wrong with that kind of regulation
where's not regulation it's real people
running their own lives and making their
own decisions I've spent much of my
career trying to correct a phenomenon
called the tragedy of the Commons where
by leaving people to have their own
agenda in terms of how they manage
natural resources leads to them being
trashed whether that's the logging of
forests the exploitation of fish docks
or in this country the trashing of the
uplands by sheep grazers who have
commoners rights so it's not necessarily
a solution to this particular set of
challenges it can go badly wrong if it's
not regulated it's not under some kind
of legal control based upon some kind of
ecological outcome that all of society
subscribes to I would say that we're far
better to have the imposition by
governments of legally binding caps on
emissions of on the recovery of nature
and to use a variety of tools to be able
to achieve those ends including some of
those tools which are at the center of
the capitalist system are not against
people having common rights but I just
don't see that that would be a solution
that would replace capitalism it's a
completely discredited notion I mean
it's been totally destroyed and ripped
down and what Garrett Hardin who who
proposed that idea did was to confuse an
open-access regime with the genuine
Commons where there is control there is
regulation by the people the fundamental
thing that both Tony and Adair are
fighting against all the time the
question why this hasn't happened
already despite decades and decades of
efforts is that capitalism not only is
it an economic system it becomes a
political system as well it empowers
those politically it empowers people who
gain the fruits of capitalism and they
prevent this change from taking place
that's why we're in Finland as a
capitalist economy is a capitalist
economy with the social democratic
government now committed to zero carbons
by 2035 why isn't that an attractive
capitalist
so we can you know there are many types
of capitalism it's not one thing or
another there are slightly better
versions out there and I think the issue
that even the slightly better versions
cannot really get to grips with the
scale and rapidity with which we need to
change they're all locked in now they
can't do it even night nice nice Norway
let's look at nice Norway
you know nice Norway just had a legal
ruling which said which was taken to
court by domestic NGOs for more drilling
in the Arctic more drilling in the
Arctic
nice Norway here saying you know we're
the better
drillers because we have higher
standards than those baddie ones you
know out in Venice they are still
drilling they're still drilling like the
one of the richest countries in the
world another example that I would love
you to look up the Amazonian Amazon
sacred headwaters an area larger than
the size of the UK with a little bit of
Wales you know added a huge area huge
area three different countries own at
Peru Ecuador Brazil this area is
pristine in is home to indigenous people
many millions of them who have lived
there in harmony looked after their
forests and now it's being opened up to
drilling and oil ok you tell me how we
fix our system now because that's just
that entire area is about to go there is
no way to stop capitalism from doing
that go to the floor well I mean for
Hana you said it there are many
different forms of capitalism and
capitalism can have New Deal's
capitalism can have new ways of doing it
which can involve significant roles for
the state alongside the private sector
you use this term New Deal we all use
the term New Deal the New Deal was a
phrase of Franklin Delano Roosevelt who
I think was the greatest American
president of the last century Franklin
Delano Roosevelt did not say he was
anti-capitalist indeed what he
introduced by his policies was the
absolute glory days of capitalism where
it delivered what capitalism can deliver
more effectively than ever before and we
can win these arguments and we have to
because the alternative if you simply
come forward in the political process
and say we're going to reject capital
frankly I think it will makes it less
likely that we will get the tough
measures required to drive the change we
needed what we're gonna we're gonna
there's so much to talk about
everyone's bursting to talk we're going
to open the debate up to all of you
before we do that I just want to reveal
the results of the prevail that's how
you voted when you came in so 38% of you
are for the motion to stop climate
collapse we must end capitalism 28% are
against and 34 percent are undecided so
you're the ones that the panel has to
persuade that we all have to watch so
we'll go to the floor this is your
chance to take part hello my question
really relates to some of the examples
that have been given of the countries
whether it's Finland or Norway I mean
frankly in the great scheme of things
rather small in terms of population if
we look at the very large populous
economies of Asia of India and of Africa
and ask the questions of how you end
capitalism or end consumerism in those
societies some are democratic some are
not democratic that just doesn't seem to
be addressed we also have the other
major economy of the United States which
seems to have gone off on a sort of
private and rather peculiar mission of
its own okay let's have the second
question number two over there
so I'm entirely sure that I agree with
either side of this question but most of
this is is directed towards the the pro
side of the question I mean as as it was
was sort of brought out I mean it's the
reasonable estimate of what fossil fuels
are subsidized for is five point six
trillion dollars I've seen that and it
was also sir but out that the cost of
renewable energy has dropped enormous li
and in fact I mean it's I think that the
most reasonable conclusion is that
renewable energy now
is less expensive than fossil energy so
given those two things I'm just that is
this really a political question in the
sense of just convincing people to
withdraw these subsidies that and remove
the the restraints on allowing renewable
energy to come forward or is it an
economic question where you need to and
you know overturn the entire system so I
would think that that it really comes
down to something that's very simple
just you you get out of the way I mean
just to end the problem solves itself
Thank You number three over there so I
had the question to both sides which was
and the pro side said that if we include
and continue with economic growth in
order to get people out of poverty we're
going to go straight into that's gonna
overshoot potentially and our resources
and environmental boundaries how do we
practically bring beyond our poverty
while also and I'm not having economic
growth the men to the against side how
do we bring about my poverty with
economic growth growth but I'm not
growing our current emissions in the
global North thank you very much so the
comparisons with Finland and Norway not
really relevant when you think about the
populations of places like Asia and
Africa who you know how do you end
capitalism when those people want to
consume what the standards of living
that perhaps we've enjoyed the cost of
renewables has gone down is this a
political question about convincing
people to withdraw subsidies or an
economic question about overturning the
system and how do you bring down poverty
without growth or equally how do you
save the club save the environment at
the expense of and yet actually allow
people to move out of poverty George do
you want to go first sure I mean it's
interesting you know picking up the
contrast between the US and Finland as
you say the u.s. far more powerful I
mean overall globally capitalism's
becoming more extreme not less extreme
we've moved away from the Social
Democratic era of capitalism the
Keynesian version of capitalism towards
this extreme neoliberal market
fundamentalist version of capitalism and
the reason for that is that capitalism
generates its own momentum people gain
power under the system and they play the
system with the use of that power are we
seeing any of the things we want to see
happening no we're not not nothing
nowhere near the scale that we need to
see them on because to go to the second
question because of the sunk costs
already invested by large capitalist
enterprises be it Exxon or BP or whoever
it might be they have got their
investments which they are trying to
protect and they use political means
like funding Donald Trump or Scott
Morrison or Jo ball tomorrow in order to
protect those investments and they gain
control over the system as a whole so
for years and years all four of us on
this panel you know and I laud and
salute Adair and Tony for all their
efforts we've been trying to fight this
system from within are we winning no we
are failing spectacularly because you
cannot fight it from within because it
generates its own power this is why we
need to be pressing and with this this
is an effort of global persuasion to say
we have to fight this from without by
demanding and creating a new system
Adair Turner let me pick up the point
about small and large population
countries in fact the greatest part of
my focus this year is on the
decarbonisation of the Chinese economy
I'll be spending about six weeks in
total in China probably not in the next
couple of weeks has been a little a
little little delay in the launch of our
next thing and what we are trying to do
there is to persuade China that it could
be a zero carbon economy by 2050
Bingbing has a phrase China 2050 a fully
developed rich economy and we have
recently produced a report called China
2050 a fully developed rich zero carbon
economy now is China a capitalist or
socialist country company economy it's
called locally a economy of socialism
with Chinese characteristics some people
think it would be better to be called a
capitalist economy with Chinese
characteristics
it's a funny mix but it has a very
dynamic private sector the solar PV plan
all's the the the batteries the EVs are
all being developed by amazingly a
dynamic Chinese entrepreneurs
overlapping with a state sector many of
which of those state-owned companies
almost act as if they were private
companies in the terms of the way they
look after the managers of those so it's
it's a complicated thing to understand
but it is certainly a form of market
economy with many of the aspects of
capitalism to it still building and I
have to say if I turned up that well let
me come back to that if I turned up
there and said okay guys what you have
to do is to reject capitalism we've get
nowhere right what happens in China is
fundamental their emissions are now 10
Giga tons of co2 12 Giga tons including
the other greenhouse gases ours are 450
and falling even on a per capita basis
they are going above UK and European
levels and to win the argument in China
there is only one way to do it which is
to convince them that it is
technologically possible for them to be
a proud rich too
society in which Chinese people enjoy
the opportunities the economic
opportunities that we enjoy that it's
technologically possible to do that and
be a zero carbon economy that's that's
how you have to win it and in order to
deliver it you also have to use powerful
market economy techniques involving
entrepreneurs competing within at one
another to drive down the cost of
batteries to drive down the cost of
electrolysis equipment to drive down the
cost of solar PV so I think when you
look at that large population country
where as I say that is where most my
focus is this year I would say the idea
that we have to approach this issue by
suggesting the rejection of capitalism
is just completely the wrong way to I'm
gonna pause you there cuz Fajardo wants
to come in yeah on the question of
subsidies so in 2009 the biggest richest
countries in the world the g7 came
together and agreed to phase out fossil
fuel subsidies 2009 okay so that's why
I'm convinced that coming together and
trying to get these agreements which
then are negated is impossible in this
system without something else happening
and that's something else happening is
first of all I think my opponents need
to accept the failures of the system and
that's why I'm here to convince you but
also to convince them to have a little
bit of a wake-up moment a little bit of
atonement a little bit of a yes we
failed because we did not recognize the
magnitude of the political weight and
the magnitude of the problems cannot be
fixed with techno managerial solutions
the second point I want to make is about
populations so many of the countries
that you suggested many of the
continents that you suggested have
extremely low per capita emissions is
not the size of the populations that
matters it's their consumption whether
they're doing it within their own
countries or offshoring it actually
elsewhere so China's emissions are
mainly coming from us and consumption by
us a lot of that is coming you can't say
something which is just not true well
that's ten percent is still it's not
it's not most it's not it's not but it's
the richest people in the in this
country that are responsible for the
bulk of the UK's emissions so the you
know the bottom seventy five percent you
know the remember the pyramid of
extraction they don't fly they don't
have cars they don't have second homes
they don't have the kind of luxury
lifestyles so I think we need to not
keep looking at whether its population
that's the driver and I think Tony's
also you know very fixated on population
as the driver of you know destruction
wise actually there's extractive system
which accumulates for the benefit of oil
to get there's a whole queue of people
up there with questions Tony I'm gonna
give you a last chance just to go back
to the questions on so I'm you know I'm
in total agreement with this idea that
we need to change the system but there
are two really important questions that
you must answer when you say that number
one is change the system to what and
then the second bit is how do you change
the system and so we need a clear
pathway between here and where we're
gonna go next and if we're going to go
somewhere where we're going to want to
take seven point seven billion people
with us we have to have an offer that is
both realistic and attractive and which
has got some means of garnering
political and democratic support for it
and so we have to be very clear I have
thought about this a fair bit and I
think that probably our best chance in
the ten years that we've got left is to
adapt the existing system into something
that can start to look like it's
ecologically sustainable if we just push
it into the margins what did we finish
up with we finish up with a lot of chaos
we finished up probably with
unemployment we finish up possibly with
people not having energy or food
literally because all of those things
are presently delivered by capitalist
organizations and without a pathway
between here and what we want to change
to I think we're going to be wasting our
time far better to advocate the change
in the existing system let's change the
hard caps in law let's change the
subsidy regime let's put a carbon tax in
place
let's give capitalism a purpose and
let's change the measure of GDP to
something which is more about what
society needs
let's take some more questions I'm going
to go just to say the final votes taking
place so hopefully you've all put your
cards in and if you're still undecided
you put the whole card in if you're not
there or there I'm gonna go up to the
balcony and take three from up there so
go for it and be brief because we not a
lot of time
Tony's five point plan it seems precise
and pragmatic please can and Jorge
respond in a meaningful engaged way to
those points and clarify to what extent
that plan could achieve your stated
future goal thank you actually agree
that's Tony's plan sounds great and I
think both Tony and Adair have admitted
that forecastle isn't to win this
argument capitalism needs to change the
big challenge is who's gonna change it
who's gonna force that change I mean who
here trusts a politician of this country
to run a bath never mind change politics
we the capitalism sells these companies
that the bear must have cattle have
known the science not for ten years at
length of 50 years I live done nothing
about it actually counteracted what they
needs to do so who is gonna actually
realistically make that change that's
what you need to convince her so we're
gonna come with you on this
so I'm a mom of three and I think I'm
going to ask a question that my kids
would probably want to know the answer
to which is so if 70 if there's 100
companies that are responsible for 70%
of co2 emissions since the 1980s the
people at the top of these companies
why don't they care are they psychopaths
and the government's that they that they
support yeah and secondly I want to ask
for a gut feeling here from you guys and
maybe a little bit of hope for me please
um have we got this can we apply the
brakes in time or all my kids who are
eight six and four gonna die prematurely
in some kind of climate related war over
resources thank you I'm gonna start at
this end of the table just for change
Adair Turner let me answer that final
question
Graham Suki said you must be pessimistic
of the intellect but optimistic of the
will you must carefully work out what
your chances of success are with the
bias to pessimism so that you are
realistic but then you must try and
change those chances I am 100% convinced
that if there were a benign deity again
above us and if she sent angels in the
night to steal all our fossil fuels by
2050 that we would by then build a zero
carbon economy and that we would hardly
notice the cost of getting there on
economic standards of living I think
there's about a 30% chance that we will
do that and my fraid my blunt belief is
that the 70% chance we're probably going
to fail so my aim in life is to turn 30
to 31 to 32 to 33 in Europe particularly
in India and in China where I work but
in order to shift it from 31 to 32 to 33
I think turning up and saying that this
thing to do is to reject capitalism
rather than reform it is likely to
reduce the probabilities that will I
will increase that from 31 to 32
33 rather than increase it but that I'm
afraid is my honest assessment of the
odds as we face them at the moment what
about the question about do those
companies simply not care I think it
varies I think there are fossil fuel
companies which now take the science
very seriously and I think there are
others and I'm not going to name which
they are which really don't at all I
think there isn't a unified approach
within the fossil fuel companies the
world I think there's quite a spectrum
look they are fossil fuel companies but
some of them want to get out some of
them are denying the science and others
are not denying it so let's take the
ones who aren't denying the science like
Shell and BP Shell won't even tell me
what its investments are in renewables
they do not feature in its annual report
because they are so tiny instead it is
trying to invest as much in fossil fuels
this year as have invested last year and
the year before in the year before it's
trying to maintain those investments
because that's where the value of its
capital is we ask why don't these people
care that people might care the system
does not care they have a fiduciary duty
towards the investors in that system to
maximize the value of their investment
that is the central premise of
capitalism what Adair and Toni are
trying to do is to take a system which
as I hope I demonstrated at the
beginning is innately unsustainable
innately drives us towards disaster and
says let's turn it round and make it
sustainable it is innately destined not
to be they are chasing unicorns and I
hope you haven't voted for them
a lot of very briefly so yeah you're
absolutely right that many of these
companies knew they've known for 40
years and their strategy was to
obfuscate deny and delay every month
they delay is usually millions of pounds
that's why I told you about what Saudi
Aramco does its strategy literally
second per second delay of the
inevitable and they have huge power
these industries to stop that they are
on trial lawyers are taking them
citizens are taking them to court I hope
as a lawyer those legal processes will
deliver justice I hope that opinions
like this debate will show to those CEOs
and everyone who's in touch with them
that they are failing humanity and their
legacy will be one of you know
destruction okay so that's what I'm
saying
but I I feel I've always liked now
ecocide is what is happening
it´ll fits the facts I want to take one
more question from the floor because as
for Hana rightly pointed out to me we
only heard from one woman's I'm gonna go
to the woman in the yellow jumper there
wait for the microphones just behind you
very brave briefly she can be Chi sorry
I only said that because you wanted a
woman the question the question I have
to stand so and the question I have I
think his you know China has had a
benevolent dictator for two and a half
thousand years he's the man you have to
persuade President Xi has a control of
such a vast potential you know when they
wanted to reduce their population they
introduced a one-child policy they did
it overnight they can create change
overnight more or less so President Xi
is is the man that you have to talk to I
think there's an invitation Adair Turner
let me just get out my mobile phone this
is a very middle-class conversation in
some ways there's no about us just to
bring it back here in the UK is it fair
for us to
ask those countries over there to change
their ways when we're not prepared to
change ours very briefly well the answer
is in this country I raise issues about
people's lifestyle right about what I or
other people have done in terms of their
transport choices their diet choices and
that's a legitimate here I don't raise
those issues in China because at the
moment they have a GDP per capita about
a third of us so I don't think it's
appropriate to raise those issues when
they're still at that level I think
you're broadly right that China it's not
a complete it's actually got more
decentralized power structures than you
might think and it has some big coal
lobbies which by the way are state-owned
coal lobbies preventing some of the move
towards renewable energy which is
primarily driven by private
entrepreneurs that happens to be the way
around in China but we do have to try
and influence the Chinese power
structure the good news is there's a lot
of there's lots of bad news about the
Chinese power structure but it is a
technocratic scientific structure that
believes in experts so when their
scientific experts say climate change is
for real the Himalayan glasses are going
to melt this is going to do terrible
things to our River flows they take it
seriously so one has to work with that
and see whether one can get more
aggressive targets for decarbonisation
than those that are in place already
George you know we're always waiting for
the right leader to come along and I
feel that one of the mistakes of the
past has to has been that we didn't
involve people we really didn't involve
people a lot of these technical plans a
lot of these solutions were never tested
on you know tested with people and were
they willing to accept that so yes
leaders matter I'm not saying that
Chinese leadership doesn't matter but
the leadership of people the voice of
people matters even more and that's why
for example extinction rebellion has
been very vociferous in demanding
citizens assemblies and selections and I
would
in response to the question about what
are your alternatives actually you know
all of the executive boards all of the
decision-making structures should now
have mandatory representation of every
cohort and of population so there are
pragmatic ways in which we can fix
governance without going to
nationalization and ownership this isn't
about that you can put you know three
three young people who sit on all of the
decisions why not you can have an Ombuds
person who looks after the rights of
citizens those who are excluded from
from voting who are literally not being
seen and heard in the current voting
system so there's lots of ways in which
practically we can reform capitalism but
I think after that reform it doesn't
look like capitalism and it won't result
in all of the egregious degradation that
we've been talking about we're gonna
wrap up the questions there because as
ever
time is short I think you've been taking
part in the final vote there's some
furious counting going on somewhere the
motion just a reminder to stop climate
collapse we must end capitalism we're
going to hear final summing up speeches
from our panel
Tony juniper if I can ask you to go
first what I've heard this evening it's
not only a discussion about economics
it's also been very much a discussion
about politics and where power lies and
if we are going to be able to change our
system in time to avoid climate collapse
an ecological catastrophe we're going to
have to find ways of getting enough
power behind the kinds of alternatives
that we think will work the question was
in the room this evening who will change
it who is going to put in place the
kinds of shifts that we need
well I'm afraid ladies and gentlemen the
good news is that it's all of us through
being voters through being activists
through being conveyors of ideas the
fantastic work that George and Farhana
have done over the years to raise
awareness to put inspiring ideas into
the public space and then to demand
action this is essential but at the same
time as having increased citizen
participation we have to have an idea of
where we're going and what we're going
do we have 10 years remaining that's
what the intergovernmental panel on
climate change tell us nevermind the
catastrophe that's unfolding in the
tropical rainforests and the coral reefs
from parallel pressures being exerted on
those places if we're going to be able
to make the most of this small window of
opportunity that remains we have to work
in the real world it's all very well
condemning capitalism and saying it
doesn't work we all agreed with its
downsides what we have to have is a
workable alternative that will get the
backing of voters it's great that
China's got a more or less benevolent
dictator but I really shudder to think
that the idea of advocating dictatorship
as a solution to this there's some very
bad experiences globally throughout the
world as a result of that particular
style of sorting problems out we have to
educate citizens free we have to inspire
them we have to get them to back the
kinds of policies that we know can work
and those policies are embedded in the
existing system that needs to change
fundamentally but changing it is going
to work better than chucking it out
Farhana over to you so i think i think
there's so much agreement that the
solutions are there and that a lot of it
is about political will but I think the
new system looks something like this
I think land is massively taxed ok land
isn't taxed at the moment what you do on
it is taxed so land comes back into some
kind of community held concept and I
think British law English law common law
has many many brilliant ways in which we
can do that many of you live in flats
where you have a lease and there's a
freehold so we can construct many
different ways in which we can all
co-owned things and it's not all
straight state owned or owned for
private profit we can put young people
we can put lay people on all of the
decision-making boards that there are in
all forms of government
I live in Camden we've already had a
citizens assembly we're now
experimenting with what we call a thing
can do pop-up space where the community
comes and collaborates they code design
and collaborate that's what we're
testing so it's far from a dictatorship
it's far from this rather nasty model
that you're you know putting forward
which is I think you know we're still
trapped in the mentality that we're all
going to go if we if we if we you know
denounce capitalism that you know we're
we're Pro Stalin or something that's
pretty much what people seem to think
and it's really not not the case and we
have a positive vision and that vision
already exists and it's called the
sustainable development goals and it's
been adopted by every single country and
it consists of an integral interrelated
17 goals which all of society every
human being means that they're not left
behind from prosperity and it means that
there's no competition no fake
competition between people and nature
between people in one country or another
we're working collaboratively together
all of that's been agreed the green
economy is by and large already or
already here actually it generates more
jobs and you're not seeing it you're not
hearing about it because they don't have
the lobbying power to influence and pay
for the kind of sophisticated ads for
billions that you
see from the fossil fuel industry which
is you know faking it and doing green
washing whilst doing business as usual
so lots and lots of things to look
forward to and nothing to lose from you
know stepping back from the edge i think
george posed the fundamental question is
there something structural in very
definition of capitalism so that it is
bound to be environmentally destructive
and i think Tony put the argument very
effectively against because he set out a
five-point plan of believable things
that you could do which if you put them
in place would have a capitalist economy
which would be environmentally sound a
capitalist economy in the only
meaningful sense of a capitalist economy
which is that most firms would be
privately owned that our restaurants
would be privately owned our hotel
company's privately owned our car
manufacturers our battery manufacturers
our solar food manufacturers would be
privately owned now in order to get
anything like Tony's program we have to
reform capitalism absolutely
fundamentally on a absolutely agree with
for Hana and Jorge that one of the
problems is that the very process of
capitalism produces concentrations of
wealth that can have a political
influence on policies which are perverse
so we have got to win the argument
against that but I think we are far more
likely to win the argument against that
if we are arguing for a reformed
regulated and controlled capitalism
rather than suggesting that we should
reject capitalism in favor of some other
model which we're not really allowed to
know what it is because I don't think
you are clear what it is because you've
got that is a bit of an article of faith
for us to accept that we'll just we'll
find this thing which we don't know what
it is and and I would put it down if at
the end of the day you're not saying
that you want to nationalize restaurants
and hotels and battery companies and car
companies and electrolysis companies
then you are accepting capitalism in any
reasonable sense of the word capitalism
George mom ba
now despite being our opponent these are
good people who are greatly Ammar and
it's a pleasure to debate with them but
the question they have repeatedly failed
to answer is why haven't we won yet
everything I've been hearing them say
I've been hearing them and people like
them and people like us say for my
entire working life 35 years we're all
in the second blue review from this
panel Tony's five point plan marvelous
brilliant fantastic I've seen it for 35
years people putting this stuff forward
why haven't we won yet and the reason we
haven't won yet is we're up against a
system which is innately Unruh formal
because of its intrinsic characteristics
we would love to reform it we would love
to have everyone coming out all the
capital is coming out of their boardroom
singing Kumbaya it is not going to
happen it is not how capitalism works
capitalism is a system for accumulation
it accumulates profit it accumulates
power it accumulates natural wealth at
other peoples expense and we are seeing
the results of that now why despite all
these marvelous things we've been
hearing are we not pulling back from
catastrophe but accelerating towards it
it's because this is not a system that
can be reformed from within this is a
system that must be overthrown and
changed this is a system whose days I
sincerely hope are numbered thank you
golly we could go on for some time this
is fabulous so I have in my hand a piece
of paper which is the final vote on the
motion to stop climate collapse we must
end capitalism now before the debates
38% of you were in favor of the motion
28% were against and 34 percent were
undecided but now 35% of you a for the
debate 58% are against and 7% of you
still don't know what you think
[Applause]
see they're really lovely thank you very
much to this fantastic panel
[Applause]
George vahana Adair Tony thank you all
very much